susan's with us in lexington hi susan
how are you
i'm well how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so um our daughter got married
and things didn't work out and so
she was three hours away she got a job
only making about 40 000. we wanted her
and our daughter close
so that we could help out while she was
at work so we bought a house for her to
live in
close to us we told her
that the rent she would still have to
pay rent but the rent would be
manageable for her
well then she found a love interest and
she
despite our beliefs she had the love
interest
move into the house um and we told her
this is not part of the deal if he's
going to live here because she is 28
this is against our beliefs we don't
agree with it
your rent is no longer subsidized so we
are raising your rent
to a thousand dollars a month
you're nicer than me i would have moved
her out
um well the house was bought in august
yes i could have gotten fair market
value so now talking to the tax
accountant
and with this man living there that's
making
significantly more than her i'm going to
say a hundred thousand dollars
a year um how do i
approach this with
explaining to her she's already knows
that it's against our beliefs
and that um
we don't agree with this but she can
definitely afford more than
a thousand dollars a month and with his
attack sometimes it's not about the
money this is not a math problem this is
not it's not about the money
you're the landlord this is a values
issue you take her out to breakfast and
you say here's the deal this is what's
going to be you got 30 days and this is
what's going to happen
do i worry about the relationship of
our granddaughter when she turns around
and you set the boundary
and your daughter ran up against that
boundary you can't hold
so she frosted you can't hold somebody
else
like you can't hold somebody else's
response to your boundaries
if she chooses to poison the well of
that relationship that's a choice she's
gonna make
but you're doing um what you feel is
best within your values
so here's the thing okay okay you
strongly believe and i do too
that what she's doing is wrong she knows
that you believe that and and the reason
you believe it's wrong is you don't
believe it's good for her
it's not i don't think she's recovered
from her marriage you don't think it's
good for her
it's a good example for the child amen
and amen
amen and amen don't believe and so all
of those reasons
all of those reasons have nothing to do
with you being selfish
these are all you loving her
right okay yes your concern is for her
it's not like you know like you have not
been violated other than
that other than the fact that she just
thumbed her nose at your
upbringing at her upbringing but you
have not been violated
you're just trying to say i don't
believe in this because i don't think
it's good for people and you're one of
the people that i don't think it's good
for
and here's what happens and you cannot
you cannot have your
uh your values and what you believe
about something harming someone
held hostage by the chance to see your
grandkid
you're being blackmailed and i don't
even know if you're there yet i feel
like you're anticipating black male is
that fair
i'm i believe so i i believe um
that she could say well
you know i can move further away sure
yeah you can do it yeah
you can do a lot of things here's where
it hurts when you think you've done
everything
right you've tried to help you in fact
you have helped
it feels unnatural when someone turns
around and bites that hand
and it because it is unnatural it hurts
it's wrong
that doesn't still have to do lovingly
kindly with no mother voice
just to smile and just say honey i love
you
you know i don't go along with this and
so you guys have 30 days to move out
here's where we are
because we can't we can't endorse this
style of life
your values are your values are your
values period